this story is about a secret restaurant
in madrid
oh yes tapas no we are here for chinese
treats whoa whoa whoa how did we get
down here again buckle up that's a long
story
it all started when we got a tip saying
madrid had the secret chinese restaurant
the most authentic food ever but very
hard to find let's go
there was no email no proper address all
reviews pointed to a mysterious
underground location we call the one
number available
no response oh what a shame no wait we
didn't give up that easily we got a
friend in madrid to get to the bottom of
it and she got us the right directions
good thinking i got it i got it there
are no signs so follow these tips
we got to madrid and followed the very
detailed instructions take notes people
go to plaza de spain truck get to the
southeast corner check find the parking
lot entrance go down the stairs double
check oh look a santa restaurant
remember there are no signs oh yeah i
forgot go down more stairs
go through the corridor walk a bit
whoa whoa wait
i think that's it
and that's how you find cafeteria yulung
zoo
better known as tisha
everyone meet you lung zoo and luffing
zoo oh mr fuji
and these two serve some of the most
genuine chinese food in spain
[Music]
these delicacies are not just your
average chinese dumplings they're from
the couple's hometown xinjiang in the
surrounding province zeijang in
southeastern china it's actually where
the majority of madrid's chinese
population is from um
really like it for a restaurant that was
this hard to find it seems like this
place never stops going
it's all cheating
[Music]
on mate what about one for us
we'll take that as a maybe
ah that was totally worth the trouble
please can we stop filming now i am
really hungry
[Music]
you